en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca de
qué quiere decir comprar acciones
acciones de una compañía creo que
tenemos la idea general sin embargo aquí
quiero ser un poco más preciso para dar
una idea más tangible de qué quiere
decir esto de adquirir acciones lo que
usualmente se piensa y bueno si es eso
lo que usualmente se piensa es que
cuando adquirimos una acción nos
volvemos un dueño un dueño parcial
parcial de la compañía de la compañía
para compañía y antes de meterme un poco
más en qué quiere decir esto me gustaría
contrastar esta idea con la de adquirir
un bono si se habla mucho de acciones y
de bonos pero son cosas distintas
acá no te vuelves dueño de la compañía
sino que te vuelves su prestamista va
entonces te vuelves un prestamista
prestado vista parcial parcial de la
compañía de la
un baño
entonces imagínate que tú quieres un
bono de mil dólares y que en total hay
mil personas que lo hacen entonces
colectivamente le están prestando a la
compañía un millón de dólares ahorita no
me voy a meter mucho en los detalles
nada más quería marcar estadística esta
distinción de este lado te vuelves dueño
parcial y acá eres un prestamista
parcial bueno regresemos acá a las
acciones y para hacer un poco más
concretos vamos a dibujar la hoja de
balance de una compañía x vale en la
compañía x bueno pues en una hoja de
balance van varios cuadritos al lado
izquierdo va el activo de la compañía va
esto de acá es el activo que voy a
pintar en color verde y es todo aquello
que tiene un beneficio o que da un
beneficio para la empresa pero en
realidad pues el activo lo podemos
pensar más en general por ejemplo una
casa es un activo porque nos da pues el
beneficio futuro de tener refugio de
protegernos del clima de los animales
salvajes un coche también es un activo
es un medio de transporte nos permite
movernos de un lado a otro el dinero en
efectivo también sería
nos permite comprar cosas prestarle
dinero a alguien también es un activo
porque nos da el beneficio futuro de que
nos paguen sin embargo si nosotros
pedimos un préstamo eso es un pasivo es
una responsabilidad pero no quiero pasar
a eso todavía vamos a empezar con el
activo entonces pensemos que la compañía
tiene 100 millones de dólares en activo
no me voy a meter mucho en de dónde sale
este numerito ahorita nada más vamos a
pensar en que es un acuerdo común de lo
que el mercado y la gente cree que vale
el terreno las fábricas los patentes el
dinero en efectivo todo lo de la
compañía va todo lo que trae un valor en
el futuro bueno además de este activo
supongamos que la compañía pidió dinero
prestado va entonces tiene que
satisfacer algunas responsabilidades y a
esas responsabilidades se les conoce
como pasivo
si va entonces pensemos que pidió en
total 80 millones 80 millones de dólares
prestados entonces tiene una deuda deuda
por 80 millones de dólares esa deuda
puede ser con el banco el banco pudo
haber logre haberle prestado todo este
dinero o bien puede ser a través de
bonos que emitió va entonces digamos y
emitió un millón de bonos y cada uno es
de 80 dólares de ahí obtuvo estos 80
millones de dólares o claro puede ser
una combinación de los dos otra vez no
me quiero meter mucho en detalles está
la deuda es un tipo de pasivo pero puede
haber más ahorita lo vamos a dejar nada
más así bueno entonces qué es lo que
sobra para los dueños de la empresa
vamos a pensarlo así mira si se vendiera
la compañía y todo está activo realmente
se vendiera en 100 millones de dólares
entonces con esos 100 millones se podría
pagar 80 millones de deuda y lo que
sobra ya sería para los dueños a eso que
sobra que en este caso serían 20
millones 20 millones de dólares se le
conoce como capital
como capital o bien como capital de los
accionistas son nada más dos formas de
llamarlo va ok entonces ahora si esto de
adquirir acciones lo que hace es que te
vuelve un dueño parcial de este cachito
de acá del capital no del activo sino
del capital entonces no sé supongamos
que esta compañía que la compañía x
emite 2 millones de acciones 2 millones
de acciones vale entonces si emite 2
millones de acciones y el capital es de
20 millones cuál sería el precio de cada
acción pues para calcular esto
tendríamos que dividir los 20 millones
de capital equitativamente entre
equitativamente entre los dos millones
de acciones que son 20 entre 12 si es el
signo de dólares se queda nos queda 10
millones con millones de cancela
entonces nos queda 1010 dólares de
capital
capital por acción por acción vale
entonces si creemos en los números y
creemos que este activo vale 100
millones y que la deuda es esto de acá
pues un precio justo según nosotros
sería de 10 de 10 dólares por acción
entonces no sé si si vamos a la bolsa de
valores y vemos que alguien lo está
vendiendo en menos lo vamos a comprar
porque nosotros creemos que vale más y
por otro lado si vemos que alguien está
dispuesto a comprar cada acción no sé en
15 dólares entonces te las vamos a
vender porque según nosotros vale menos
ok aquí está todo muy abstracto lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es pasar a un
ejemplo de la vida real va para que
veamos cómo se aplica esto en el mercado
real entonces aquí tengo información que
saqué de fuentes tradicionales de
finanzas en internet son los registros
de una cierta compañía que es anónima
bueno tenía su nombre pero yo se lo
quite tienes puntos extras y adivinas
cuál es la compañía pero ve lo que puse
acá fue la actividad de compraventa de
las acciones y de este lado tenemos la
hoja de balance nada más
está escrita renglón por renglón lo que
vamos a hacer es pasar esto a un
diagrama como el de acá arriba para ver
que esto sí se aplica en la vida real
bueno entonces empecemos con con el
pasivo lo voy a poner otra vez en un
rectángulo verde entonces eso de ahí es
el no empecemos con el activo con el
activo estoy es el activo y vámonos acá
a leer la información aquí hay
información para dos años vamos a
utilizar el de 2009 el otro está nada
más como referencia digo de todas formas
esto pues ya está muy pasado de moda
verdad 2009 ya fue hace que como cuatro
años bueno no importa ahorita no
queremos invertir nada más queremos ver
cómo pasar la información al dibujito de
la hoja de balance entonces vamos a ver
qué dice por acá activo queremos el
activo total aquí está es de 30 millones
de dólares le voy a poner aquí 30
millones de dólares vamos a leer tantito
para ver qué significan estas cosas aquí
dice activo corriente eso es activo así
como muy líquido que se puede comprar y
vender rápidamente el efectivo es súper
líquido es
los activos más líquidos sino el más
líquido que existe cuentas recibirles
eso es dinero que nos deben que nos van
a pagar en menos de un año
inventarios es nuestro producto que está
por ahí almacenado y que podemos vender
también rápidamente otro activo
corriente pues eso puede ser no sé a lo
mejor compramos acciones de otra empresa
entonces eso es otro activo corriente
eso en total es de 18 millones y además
hay otro tipo de activos verdad que no
son tan corrientes bueno que no que no
son fáciles de vender ni de comprar y
que es propiedades planta y equipo ya
platicamos un poco de eso allá arriba
aquí dice otro activo esto puede ser no
sé por ejemplo patentes o algo así
entonces aquí son como como 11 millones
y cachito aquí 18 y cachito entonces en
total de 30 millones de dólares bueno
ahora pasemos al pasivo pasemos al
pasivo lo primerito que dice por ahí es
pasivo corriente entonces ahorita déjame
poner esto un poco más bonito
ahorita vamos al pasivo corriente
entonces el pasivo corriente como el
activo corriente es pasivo que tenemos
que pagar rápido a corto plazo o sea
como en menos de un año usualmente va
entonces pueden ser préstamos que nos
hizo el banco que tenemos que pagar
pronto o bonos que están a punto de
vencerse y así entonces aquí le ponemos
pasivo pasivo también tenemos deuda a
largo plazo esto puede ser una deuda con
el banco pues más a largo plazo como en
cinco o diez años vale
en total cuánto nos da pues de pasivo
corriente son como 16 millones y
cachitos de deuda a largo plazo son 5
millones y cachito eso es como 21 y 2
cachitos vamos a ponerle vamos a ponerle
que son 22 millones 22 millones de
dólares en pasivo
bueno entonces acá en el dibujo en la
hoja de balance que estamos dibujando
cuánto nos quedaría el capital pues
sería lo que tenemos menos lo que
debemos a sí que serían 8 millones de
dólares de capital
vale de capital si nos fijamos acá en la
hoja de balance que nos da la empresa
dice que son 8.396 millones y bueno sí o
sea tiene sentido que no sea una
cantidad cerrada porque acá redondeamos
verdad de este lado tenemos números
cerrados acá no entonces déjame ponerle
aquí al ladito que son 8.4 millones
bueno esta es una mejor aproximación
vale vamos a ver qué más podemos decir
pues pensemos ahora en en el valor de
cada acción vale cuando tendríamos que
pagar por cada una de las acciones acá
tenemos el número total de acciones si
te das cuenta está dividido entre
acciones básicas y acciones diluidas
ahorita no me quiero meter mucho en la
distinción entre unas y otras porque
sería medio latoso pero como los números
son muy parecidos vamos a ponerle que
son que como dos puntos 78 dos puntos 78
millones de acciones vale entonces vamos
a hacer la cuenta mira el valor en
libros el valor en libros del capital
es de 8.4 millones esto del valor en
libros es lo que nos dicen los
contadores lo que nos dicen los
contadores de la empresa de la compañía
y en total tenemos 2.78 millones de
acciones entonces si queremos el precio
por acción lo que tendríamos que hacer
es dividir esto los 8.39 millones de
dólares entre esta cantidad de acciones
que son dos puntos 78 millones de
acciones vamos a ver cuánto da para eso
voy a sacar mi calculadora la prendo y
borró y es 8.39 8.39 entre entre dos
puntos 78 enter 3.017 lo voy a redondear
como 3.02 dólares vale entonces el
precio por acción
voy a poner precio por acción que
sacamos a partir de esta información es
de 3 3.0 2
muy bien entonces esto de acá sería un
precio justo si creemos totalmente en
los contadores de la empresa esto es en
lo que tendríamos que comprar o vender
cada una de las acciones pero vamos a
ver qué piensa en el mercado al respecto
vámonos a la información de acá que es
la información de compraventa mira la
última transacción que se realizó fue de
2.58 dólares la acción se vendió en
menos que estos 3.02 a un precio de
descuento aquí se puede ver esto pues
bueno puede ser porque porque o sea se
puede deber a que la persona que vende
cree que pues no sé qué lea que el
activo de la empresa vale menos o que
los contadores están haciendo la
contabilidad de una forma un poco rara o
no sea incluso el mercado puede pensar
que esta empresa ya le va a empezar a ir
mal va no se puede ser que el producto
ya no sea novedoso y que entonces vayan
a bajar las ventas etcétera por otro
lado si hay compradores que están
comprando en 2.58 y eso se puede deber a
que crean que si vale más que está cerca
de tres dólares cada una de las acciones
tanto si están comprando bueno vamos a
analizar un poquito más de la
información aquí para ver qué te puedo
contar aquí está el precio vil
el precio vil es el precio que ofrecen
los compradores que es de 2.48 lo voy a
poner aquí porque no se ve muy bien es
2.48 también está el precio
asq que es lo que un vendedor está
pidiendo por por acción 2.58 de este
lado tenemos rangos del día no hay
información en rango de 52 semanas a eso
está bueno mira en el año hubo un
momento en el cual estuvo en un dólar
con 20 centavos entonces pues quien lo
compre en ese momento ya hizo su agosto
verdad por qué por qué está ahorita en
2.58 se duplicó bueno más verdad que el
valor quedó más arriba que el doble
entonces le fue súper bien esta persona
y aquí de volumen dice cero volumen
promedio de tres meses eso es la
cantidad de acciones que se vende por
día son tres mil doscientos noventa
vamos a ver qué más hay por aquí
interesante la capitalización de mercado
a eso está interesante no te platicado
de
capitalización del mercado mira aquí
dice que es 7.0 6 millones y esto es
justo lo que el mercado piensa que vale
el capital de la empresa o sea de este
lado tenemos que el valor en libro el
valor en libro es de 8.4 millones el
capital valen 8.4 millones según los
contadores de la compañía pero acá el
valor de mercado es de 7.206 7.05 para
entonces la capitalización de mercado
mercado dice que es de 7.7 punto 06 7.06
va y eso como se calcula como le hacen
para calcularlo pues lo que hacen es
tomar el precio el precio de las
acciones según el mercado y eso
multiplicar multiplicarlo por la
cantidad total de acciones vamos a ver
qué pasa cuando hacemos eso entonces
déjame tomar la calculadora la
encendemos entonces entonces son dos
puntos 78 millones de acciones 2 puntos
78 y eso hay que multiplicarlo por el
precio de mercado que es 2
58 por acción por 2.58 y nos queda 7.17
7 puntos 17 millones 7 puntos 17
millones bueno eso es un poco distinto a
lo que dice acá arriba asegura es por
algún error de redondeo o porque están
promediando el precio bit con el ask no
sé pero bueno está muy cercano y así se
calcula sale espero que todo esto que te
conté te haya ayudado y básicamente la
idea era profundizar sobre qué significa
adquirir acciones en el mundo real y ver
un ejemplo de esto